to show you check out these pictures now  from mohave county arizona this is  northwest arizona just on the other side  of our border with arizona now deputies  there tell us that they responded to a  lot of calls  last night and earlier today most of  these pictures were showing you coming  in from calls where people were being  rescued from high rising water look at  that suv that was flipped over this area  received more than two inches of rain  last night and although one family got  caught in the flooded road  that was after they were fleeing their  home that was flooded thankfully  everyone seemed to have made it out okay  but i'm telling you this water can rise  so quickly overtaking roads you really  should never enter a flooded roadway it  is just too dangerous